on va vers une poussée assez forte des
prix qui est liée à un
redémarrage un choc absolument
incroyable qu'on a su bien le choc que
l'économie a subi en 2020 en 2020 avec
la crise qu vide où on a quand même
fermé pendant plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois tout l'appareil productif
mondiale c'est un choc absolument nous
ils virent c'est miraculeux enfin c'est
extraordinaire qu'on soit retourné à peu
près à un niveau d'activité d'il ya deux
ans après un tel choc c'est déjà
incroyable donc c'est normal que vous
ayez espèces dont deux chocs qui fait
que ben on ajuste les capacités de
réaction en termes d'énergie en termes
de matières premières en termes de
transport maritime et que vous ayez une
espèce d'onde de choc qui se diffuse sur
un an un an et demi peut-être deux en
économie qui va effectivement aboutir
qui est en train d'aboutir à une
inflation et à une hausse de prix est
assez forte mais fondamentalement les
les moteurs de cette baisse de prix le
moteur de la technologie ils ont pas
ralenti et au contraire ils ont même
accéléré on a accéléré sur le plan
technologique pendant la crise du
communal a accéléré ce plan médical on
aller beaucoup plus vite sur l'arrêt sur
la production de vaccins que je
composais avant on a accéléré sur la
numérisation des entreprises sur le
digital elles ont gagné pour le mans
cinq ans et ça c'est un facteur de
baisse de +61 facteurs déflationnistes
vous allez baisser les loyers vous avez
20 des surfaces d'être des coûts de
transport vous allez bcd des coûts dans
les entreprises et donc on fait le
fondement déflationniste structurelle de
l'économie il est toujours là et donc
vous allez compenser aujourd'hui par une
très forte hausse des matières premières
mes maîtres la première concerne deçà
des 100 après la dernière hausse des
matières premières qu'on a eu c'est
entre 2012 et 2014 de pétrole était
monté de façon très élevé il est
retourné ensuite et on est rentré en
inflation négative en début de déflation
en 2016 je pense que ça se sait qui
c'est ça qui va se passer aujourd'hui
donc je ne crois pas du tout retour de
l'inflation je suis c'est pas tout à
fait le consensus de marché je suis très
conscient mais on n'est pas obligé décor
est le marché je pense qu'au contraire
on rentrera dans une période de très
basses inflation peut-être à horizon 12
18 mois je sais pas très bien c'est
qu'il faut le temps que cette hausse
absorbe mais quand elle va redescendre
il va se cumuler avec cette baisse cette
déflation structurelles dont moi je vois
plutôt une logique de baisse de prix à
l'horizon 2023 2010 oui
[Musique]